qué fracción del círculo está pintado de
rojo y para eso vamos a contar el total
de las piezas iguales que tiene este
círculo y contemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
esto quiere decir que el círculo tiene 9
piezas de las cuales 8 están dibujadas o
bueno están pintadas de rojo vamos a
escribir entonces 8
y porque lo estoy escribiendo así
déjenme les explico esto normalmente
nosotros escribiríamos como fracciones
de 9 piezas de hecho vamos a escribirlo
con rojo para que nos acerquemos 8 de 9
piezas que al parecer estaban en gris o
blanco están pintadas
están
pintadas
de rojo
y normalmente así escribimos las
fracciones nosotros un número que es el
numerador sobre el denominador ocho
novenos están pintados de rojo sin
embargo con escribir en la computadora
escribimos 8
sobre 9 es por eso que cambiamos la
línea horizontal por una diagonal ocho
de cada nueve están pintadas de rojo
vamos a regresar a nuestro ejemplo y
escribamos lo hay ocho partes de nueve
están pintadas de rojo es decir ocho
novenos de este círculo están pintados
en rojo vamos a comprobar respuesta
y es correcta vamos a hacer un par más
qué fracción del círculo está pintado en
rojo contemos 12345678 esta vez tiene 8
partes iguales cuántas están pintadas en
rojo 1 2 3 4 5 tenemos 5 partes de 8 x 5
octavos están pintados de rojo
comprobemos respuesta
perfecto una más
qué fracción de la barra está pintada de
rojo contemos cuántas partes tiene esta
barra 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 cuántas están
pintadas de rojo 1 2 3 4 5 6 es decir 6
partes de las 8 totales que hay 6
octavos están pintados de rojo
comprobemos nuestra respuesta
y es correcta